you know you know rogan's not working
tonight what what what are you talking
about he said it was a conflict issue
i'm not buying it wait a minute you're
saying that because
hold on chris you probably just got
something else there's like maybe you
got sick or something chris there's an
explanation
chris what happened it's fine look at me
i know there's a probably a very logical
explanation but he was probably has held
a lot of tickets and it was just stay in
the center he
is spreading rumors hey chris
they sweat they switch them you don't
think spotify had anything to do with it
do you no chris i
uh chris the guy's a businessman yeah
wait wait what happened all right chris
who owns espn who owns espn
disney
hit it
come back to us please
chris
what happened nothing to do guys i hate
you yet to bring him out man i'm
thinking about you i'm sorry i'm sorry i
did that i needed to see that
mad chris is a centrist politically but
sometimes with the insanity they're
pushing him they push him he's got to
wear his mask behind his ears and what
happens is they they start pushing them
over you guys are getting that he
becomes far right chris and we want to
keep we want to keep i'm in the center
hold on
i